To me,
it's very interesting that it's so
controversial,
the fact that it's,
it's not deterministic because
throughout my life and medicine I have
never,
I very rarely get a test back that is so
deterministic,
so you know,
even when I was pregnant and,
and I get a variety of tests back and
they say,
okay,
you're,
this is cutting your risk down for
having a down syndrome baby.
But it's never,
it's never 100 percent,
um,
unless I did the Amnio,
which I did not do.
So,
you know,
I've,
and even things like cholesterol,
if I,
if I find out have high cholesterol,
again,
that's a risk base.
It means that I have a risk factor for
heart disease.
But it didn't tell me anything specific.
It doesn't,
you know,
some people even do very well with
having high cholesterol.
It doesn't say specifically you are
going to die of heart disease.
Um,
so in my opinion,
my,
you know,
I've been very comfortable with having
diagnostic tests that tell me that I
might be at higher risk or lower risk
based on some,
some information.
So for the clerk to example that my
husband has,
he already knew that he had a family
history of Parkinson's disease and now
he knows that there is a genetic basis
for it and that he carries that genetic
basis for it.
So,
you know,
again,
he already knew that there was the
family history he has up there and he
has gone through a lot of the
literature.
One of the things that he's found is
that it's not that well studied just yet
because it was a relatively recent
discovery,
but there is information,
there are about things you can do to
prevent Parkinson's.
So that could be changing your diet,
exercising more and potentially drinking
coffee.
Um,
and those are all three things that he
does.
And,
and again,
going to the critics,
all three of those things are great for
his health regardless.
So he has lost weight.
He is much more vigilant about,
um,
you know,
eating vegetables and he is trying to
drink a little bit of coffee.
So,
so I'm really,
you know,
I'm really happy that we got that
information because even if it comes out
later that Oh,
he has other genes that um,
you know,
decreases risk and therefore he's sort
of at average risk for Parkinson's.
You know,
what I'm used to getting that kind of
information in that kind of change in
health care.
And two,
I'm happy because he made a lifestyle
change that fundamentally made them
healthier.